Steve Bannon is now going after me on
his program not just with the
seriousness of the Satan club and
brother Pac-Man anytime you want to come
over or sit down and we can walk you
through it it's it's not mental else and
we're not going to let you divert the
attention away from what the problem is
we are going to shut down these clubs
and these schools we're not going to let
little children
in public schools
be exposed to these demons and that's
what they're the Demonic all right so
anyway listen uh Steve Bannon is welcome
on this program quite literally anytime
I'm not super interested in talking with
him about the satanic temple but I guess
if that's what it takes to get him on
I'm willing to willing to do it there
are many other things I would like to
talk to Steve Bannon about including his
role in bringing forward one of the most
disastrous presidencies in the history
of the United States certainly in the
last 50 years
um he's welcome on the program quite
literally anytime